Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
As you know from this series, fluid simulation
techniques that are able to create high fidelity
video footage are in abundance in computer
graphics research.
These techniques all have their own tradeoffs,
and when we evaluate them, we often use terms
like first or second-order accuracy, which
are mathematical terms.
We often have to evaluate these techniques
against each other by means of mathematics,
because this way, we can set up consistent
and unbiased comparisons that everyone understands
and agrees upon.
However, ultimately, in the show business,
what matters is how the viewers perceive the
end result, whether they think it looks fake,
or if it keeps their suspension of disbelief.
We have the choice of not only simulation
techniques, but all of them also have their
own set of parameters.
For instance, the higher the resolution of
our simulations, the more high-frequency details
appear in the footage.
However, after a point, increasing the resolution
further is extremely costly, and while we
know what is to be gained in terms of mathematics,
it is still unknown how well it would do with
the users.
So the ultimate question is this: what do
I get for my money and time?
This paper provides an exhaustive user study
to answer this question, where the users are
asked to look at two different simulations
and as a binary choice, tell us which is the
one they perceived to be closer to the reference.
The reference footage is a real-world video
of a water sloshing in a tank, and the other
footage that is to be judged is created via
a fluid simulation algorithm.
Turns out that the reference footage can be
almost anything as long as there are some
splashing and sloshing going on in it.
It also turns out that after a relatively
favorable breaking point which is denoted
by 2x, further increasing the resolution does
not make a significant difference in the user
scores.
But boy, does it change the computation times!
So this is why such studies are super useful,
and it's great to see that the accuracy of
these techniques are measured both mathematically,
and also how convincing they actually look
for users.
Another curious finding is that if we deny
access to the reference footage, we see a
large change in different responses and a
similar jump in ambiguity.
This means that we are reasonably bad at predicting
the fine details, therefore, if the simulation
pushes the right buttons, the users will easily
believe it to be correct even if it is far
away from the ground truth solution.
Here is a matrix with a ton of rendered footage.
Horizontally, you see the same thing with
different simulation techniques, and vertically,
we slowly go from transparent above to opaque
below.
To keep things fair and really reveal which
choices are the best bang for the buck, there
are also comparisons between techniques that
have a similar computation time.
In these cases, the Fluid Implicit Particle.
FLIP in short and the Affine Particle in Cell,
are almost unanimously favorable.
These are advanced techniques that combine
particle and grid-based simulations.
I think this is highly useful information
for more time critical applications, so make
sure to have a look at the paper for details.
There are similar user studies with glossy
and translucent material models and much more
in the paper.
The source code of this project is also available.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!